in a universe so vast is there any hope
of us traveling fast enough so that we
could visit the far-off realms of space
will we ever be able to plant a flag in
the most distant quadrants of the cosmos
we are not going to achieve interstellar
flight in our lifetime we may be as far
from reaching other stars as Leonardo da
Vinci was from realizing an airplane he
had the idea but it took another 400
years before that began flight even so
it hasn't stopped scientists from
imagining the theoretical possibilities
of interstellar travel
one sense possibility is a cosmic freak
show a much theorized portal through
space called a wormhole
so wormhole is basically a thin tube of
space that connects to very very distant
parts of space so it's almost like a
tunnel it's a little part of space you
go in there and you pop out somewhere
else in the universe on tunnel through
space
shortcut through the billions of
light-years separating the farthest ends
of the universe it begs the question of
how anything could bore a hole through
space the wormhole is basically like a
tunnel through space itself that can
connect one region to another region
potentially very far away so to
illustrate that we're taking space and
imagining it as this two-dimensional
sheet of paper so we have a wormhole
mouth that you can go in and then the
other end is a place you can go out so
you imagine a tunnel that goes into
there and comes out of there
and you might say well it would take me
longer to get from one place to another
if I went through that tunnel than if I
just took the direct route through
ordinary space but the point is that
Einstein tells us that space and time or
curved they're flexible so we can
imagine picking up this piece of paper
and curling these two regions so that
they're close to each other
then you go into that end of the
wormhole you come outside the other end
and there's a shortcut in between them
in which the distance is not that much
so the wormhole provides a way that you
can travel what appears to be a very
long distance in a very short period of
time and it's for that reason that
wormholes have found a special place in
science fiction if you want to write a
science fiction novel you might want to
be able to get across the galaxy very
quickly and you don't want to be limited
by the speed of light so a wormhole can
be a shortcut it can be a way to get
around all the space that you have to
travel through if you believe that the
speed of light really is a speed limit
you can't go faster than the speed of
light the wormhole provides you away
maybe to still go slower than the speed
of light but get to where you want to go
much faster because the distance is much
shorter it's really just a shortcut
through space itself a wormhole might
also empty into another time that's
because wormholes are portals through
the fabric of space and time while they
could theoretically link different
locations in space they could also
theoretically link up different
locations in time because space and time
are mixed up together you could actually
not only end up in a different part of
space by going through the wormhole but
you could also end up in the past you
could end up in a different part of time
you could go into your own past then
come visit yourself before you entered
the beginning of the wormhole so you
could have a wormhole it goes from your
living room to your dining room they
might be five years apart so you enter
one this year
you come back five years ago and if you
take the paper with you you've got some
good chances of doing well in the stock
exchange